we've been talking all day long about
both Durham because it was was it 32
years ago today 1988 first hit a theater
one of the greatest movies of all time
period and I'm not just saying that
because he's on the phone line it's kind
enough to call in and he's one of the
favorite people that my wife and I have
met here in Los Angeles but he's a
director of Bull Durham and other great
films he is none other than ron shelton
how are you wrong well I'm glad you
called it because I can stop watching
the Nebraska State cornhole championship
for the wood how does it turn out Ron I
don't mind it being spoiled how does it
turn out I guess happy anniversary Ron
32 years ago today I didn't know you
know we were just trying to have no idea
that the movie would be received the way
it has been and you know you just it was
my first movie as a director just hope
somebody goes the theater so you can get
another job and so it really was a
glorious shock how it was how well it
played yeah when did you first realize
it was gonna he had a hit on your hands
Ron well the reviews were great and you
never quite know it didn't test all that
well which is strange because audiences
laughed and cheered and then and then
wrote on the cards 47 ways I could make
it better so we weren't sure but it did
great out of the box and it just kind of
chugged along all summer so after the
second weekend when people kept going it
didn't it didn't go down we we thought
we were in good shape it did
now did everyone you want to be cast in
the roles get the get the gigs or is
there somebody that uh that that you you
wanted that didn't make it or vice versa
no we got everybody it was a long
process
I had Kevin because I showed him the
script and he was on board and every
woman 40 did a great audition for Annie
it was amazing and then we went ISM got
the
and was you know couldn't imagine
anybody else but the nuke LaLoosh part
was hard to cast to be honest because a
lot of guys look like young versions of
Caitlyn and you couldn't have young
Kevin and older Kevin so we had to find
somebody who was complete and and
lovable and goofy and you know and Tim
had never been in a movie he'd actually
been in Howard the Duck but he didn't
tell us no that was a flop of all time
so he didn't he told us he had never
been in a show okay now we had Tom
Verducci on before Ron the baseball
reporter overheard us talking about this
he said the current Braves manager lent
his glove his catcher's mitt for Kevin
in this film is that a true story I've
never heard that one before nerd girl
yeah laughter yeah snicker there was a
bunch of guys yes Grady little was the
manager of the actual Durham Bulls we
came in to shoot right after the season
was over and he was just a guy right
Crash Davis at the end of our movie
grinding it out and so I met him and I
said can you find some minor league ball
players and college ball players who are
needing a couple of months work and run
the baseball and so great a little round
of baseball for us long before he became
the manager of the Dodgers and the Red
Sox and snikt or something I was around
and maybe in the minor leagues because
that was a Braves organization during
those days and yeah somehow we got his
glove I mean I've stayed in touch with
snip over the years and so it's in this
case he's not lying
oh my gosh oh wow so what would you
consider the best baseball movie of all
time Ron
I'm pretty tough on baseball movies I
love the original bad news bears be
honest yes and then later I coach Little
League and discovered to be wait really
way too much like Walter Matt
were you having a tumblr - and the
dugout is though you're saying Ron the
league put an ankle bracelet around the
out of my girl so I finally retired when
myself got old enough I could free him
from father but you love Bad News Bears
anything else because the other ones
that we chose you know I mean I think
there's good things about a lot of
sports movies I like are kind of been
around the weather hustler is one of my
top movies the full movie except the
sports movie okay there's a great boxing
movie that very few people are seen by
it's called Fat City it introduced a guy
named Jeff Bridges and it's kind of the
lower rungs of boxing I've ever seen men
to anybody you can find on Netflix now
thank City this sporting life is a
English rugby movie with Richard Harris
it just kills me every time you go
indeed you're on that's deep okay I'm
going deep it's hard for me to watch
sports movies kinda hypercritical not
bad I bet you I bet you are
well Hoosiers is is up there for me yeah
I love that you know we had David on
spar the other day talking about
Hoosiers and Rudy and what's real and
what's not
I guess that's what makes a great sports
movie even what you're describing
certainly with Bull Durham is - what's
real and it just feels so real when you
watch this it's like you're watching
behind the scenes just as a in a comedy
and a love story form it's true it's
true it's it stands the time before
which you know I can't filmmaker can't
compete with television and he's a fool
to try because television sports on
television is is just you know off the
charts
and there's 17 cameras and replay from
17 angles and and you can't do that and
but what I can do is I can put my one
camera all the places so 17 cameras
can't go and that's all I try to do go
on the bus trips go to the home with a
locker go to the shower you know go in
the apartment with
girl or doing whatever they're doing and
in the manager's office and and that's I
can I can go or TV camps and that's
where I live all right last one for Iran
if you could make a sequel for any of
your sports movies which one would you
endeavor which one would you do it
before I'm trying I'm trying to make a
movie about a former major league
baseball star who tries to make it on
the golf tour the way that guys like
Mike Schmidt and bench
okay lot of guys do SH molt and it would
sort of be the end of the Bull Durham
ten cup trilogy so that's what I'm
trying to do are you you're not you're
not joking this is what you're trying to
do right now I can tell when you see
what's been doing we're you know putting
it together it takes a little while
because it's not a Marvel I love you rod
you are you are the best thanks for the
call I would see that by the way all of
us were just we all sat straight up in
our chairs everyone yeah yeah we would
do it right back at you thank you that's
uh that's the great ron shelton you bet
oh my gosh right amazing in costner
shelton together let's do it let's do it
well go in the tower
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here